wow it's a real alien what is that dot
it could be anything this is interesting
but you can immediately tell what's
going on it could be an alien i could
literally make you that shot in after
effects and it would look exactly the
same
so what are you telling me jamie there's
a ufo yesterday yeah what does the us
government know about ufos newly leaked
video allegedly shows one of the us
navy's stealth ships tracking an unknown
object in the sky there's stuff flying
in our airspace we don't know what it is
we need to find out so a few months ago
the pentagon released a series of ufo
videos we have footage of things flying
we don't know what they are whichever
immediately turns into them saying the
pentagon has alien footage
ufos is not aliens ufo stands for
unidentified flying object i'm sure a
bunch of people know that but it's
become synonymous like flying saucers
and aliens what they did though is they
were like let's stop calling them ufos
let's call them uaps unidentified aerial
phenomenon it's totally more accurate
because sometimes like what you're
filming isn't a physical object and it
could be
a trick of light or a shadow and like
might not be something physical but just
the way
a sensor or camera reacts to light we
wanted to take our visual effects artist
eye and apply it to these videos because
we spend a lot of time analyzing footage
analyzing pixels trying to figure out
what makes things look fake a big part
of our time is spent
trying to replicate what an image looks
like once it's passed through a lens and
a camera you know that's what visual
effects truly are it's not just going oh
does something look real it's no does
this look like the image was captured
with a real camera i haven't seen any of
these videos and it's mostly just
because i saw like a screenshot of one
i'm like okay same old thing you know
here's a dot
you know
mass effect
so what does it say is it a flying
triangle alien well it seems to grow and
shrink like an iris is adjusting or
something like that
[Laughter]
that's what i see
okay so this guy this guy literally held
his phone up to his like night vision
monocular all right and those little
white specks
are the sensor of this night vision
camera
kind of fritzing out a little bit with
noise okay i see a bokeh bokeh's okay so
when you see something that's out of
focus in the background basically it's
it's the shape of the
iris of a lens all the light has is
forced through the iris that's in front
of your sensor and whatever the shape of
that iris is is the
uh shape your bokeh is going to be seems
like this is maybe a
like a triangular iris three bladed iris
three bladed iris now we're all used to
circles because our lenses have circular
apertures and in fact the more expensive
the lens the more blades on the aperture
so it becomes rounder and it doesn't
have like a hexagon stop sign shape but
the cheaper lenses have less aperture
blades and really cheap lenses you only
need like three blades you know
it's cheap and it's easy you're not
worried about trying to make a nice
bokeh in the background you just need to
open and close the aperture and this is
not a film camera that is using it's not
a dslr this is a infrared camera so the
lens in this camera is cheap i think to
me this video is clearly clearly clearly
just an out of focus airplane and all
you need to do is look at the top of the
flagpole in the right corner or even the
stars in the background and you can see
that they also take on a triangular
shape yeah yeah you're right it's
literally just the bokeh okay so there's
nothing special about this at all
there's actually nothing special about
this i could recreate this footage with
basically zero effort taking a night
vision monocular and then i just put my
phone into it like how is this even
newsworthy yeah this is actually this is
the thing that kind of makes me angry
it's like this is so obviously just out
of focus footage this is going through
newsrooms and like these are
professionals that work with cameras and
you can immediately tell what's going on
and then they purposefully kind of cover
it up so they can act like it's
something interesting to talk about i
don't think we developed that technology
on this planet
all right this next clip is from the
pentagon
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
there's something there i think that's a
physical object i think it's a physical
object too so just a little bit of
context we're in an airplane and the
airplane is above the water and it seems
like whatever they're looking at is
below them but it's like what is this
it's like a dot that's like how many
pixels is that like maybe a collection
of
up to 12
individual pixels
you know i'm saying like there's not a
lot to work with here it's just here's a
dot that's flying around i have a pretty
strong theory of what's going on here
this is one of the more interesting ones
it's not so obviously oh it's an out of
focus object like this is
this is interesting but i think this is
just a trick
of parallax motion
a trick of parallax
motion i think what we're dealing with
here is a bird not a drone not an
incredibly fast flying ship here's why
first off
we are not sitting still as our point of
view we are in an airplane the
airplane's moving notice that when
they're not locked on the bird the ocean
isn't moving the airplane's not sitting
still the airplane's moving fast i think
what's actually happening is the camera
is stabilizing itself to whatever it's
pointed to so it's pointing to the ocean
and so it's locked there there are
places moving forwards but the camera is
locked to that point in the ocean like a
gimbal and so it feels like we're
sitting still but we're not the camera's
just tracking that one spot so it can
stay locked there and then we see a bird
fly by it looks like the bird's flying
really fast but imagine for a minute if
you will and you have a bird up in the
air and we have an airplane going
300 miles an hour 400 miles an hour and
the bird is flying in the opposite
direction of the airplane all right so
you see a little thing go across the
screen not because the birds going 300
miles an hour because they're going 300
miles an hour and it makes it look like
they're going super super fast let's do
a little experiment here sam i want you
to be the bird here okay i have it on
the end of this stick it's a little
little yellow bird i'm gonna be the
airplane and i just want to see what
happens to the background
okay lock on here we go three two
one action
all right so sam didn't even move that
part's going so fast it does look like
it's moving yep i think that's the
effect we're looking at here i think the
bird's probably flying you know decently
fast but what if it's ufo
it could be a bird
it could be a tiny tiny alien moving at
the speed of a bird as well yeah so
we've gone from what i think is an easy
to debunk to a medium challenging debunk
let's go to one that i think is the most
challenging of all of them
okay well everyone is trying to debunk
these ufo videos i did a little bit of
research on my own and i think there's
quite a few things in here that people
aren't going to notice and i want to
tell you exactly what those things are
courtesy of today's sponsor squarespace
number one let's go what is the first
thing that we see okay we see a glowing
orb
in the middle of two lines glowing orbs
well they are beautiful and if you've
ever wanted to get a beautiful website
of your own you can get started with
squarespace they have beautiful
award-winning templates and 24 7
customer service in case you get stuck
okay well that's that's all we know
about that one let's move on i've got
the second video pulled up here and the
first thing you're gonna notice is that
uh there's two people talking if you
listen to the audio of this they're
coordinating together as a team and with
squarespace you can use their multiple
contributors tool it's pretty great you
don't need to use one access for all the
people that are contributing to your
website no you can break it down focus
on who's good at what get them situated
and make the whole website better off
all right i've got the third image
pulled up here now this one is the most
compelling the most interesting because
there's a tiny object flying
fast and guess what oh right here right
here boom he catches it with the
tracking device that he has from his jet
plane he's looking down he's tracking it
just like squarespace's traffic
overviews tools with squarespace you're
going to be able to see who comes and
goes on your site you know what pages
they're frequenting where they're coming
from and a lot of other important
details that you're going to need to
make your site better off over the long
term squarespace has some of the best
analytics that's why we use them that's
why we love them okay i've reviewed all
three videos and i think it's pretty
obvious the first thing that you're
going to want to do if you see footage
like this for the first time is is get
it out on social media through
squarespace's connected social media
accounts tool you can make one post on
your squarespace website and have that
automatically format and go out to a
bunch of other social media platforms
after you post them on social media well
maybe you want to host them as videos on
the internet well guess what through
squarespace's videoblocks tool you can
do exactly that so anyways head on over
to squarespace.com corridor crew to get
10 of your first purchase that's
squarespace.com corridor crew see you
later
[Applause]
orb
he shaped his ufo like the full of
lorpazor
[Laughter]
what we're looking at here isn't a ufo
but a flying alien in the flesh
it does have a very ufo like shape but
notice how it rotates each time the
camera rotates the orientation of the
alien's body
the shape that we see here changes as
the camera's orientation changes so its
shape is defined by the camera whatever
that is
it's not that shape first off
this one is a challenging one i think
we're looking at two different things
happening here so this is a thermal
camera it's not just infrared it's full
on thermal so it goes pretty far down to
infrared spectrum i think we're looking
at a lens flare a heat lens flare
when people say lens flares they
probably think of that whole streak of
like you know circles across the frame
i'm just talking about a literal flare
bloom it's it's a one single bright
object in the center of frame and what's
giving it its shape is the shape of the
blue mount around it so it's just one
bright object like this and the way it
blooms i think is giving it that oval
shape what's there in the distance is
either an airplane or a mylar balloon
reflecting the sun and it's reflecting
the sun directly into the camera lens
here and they're going whoa it's so hot
and bright when you use thermal cameras
or cameras like this they have a certain
dynamic range if something blows it out
so to speak you get the halo effect like
if something's super ultra bright
sometimes that will basically tell the
sensor like oh it's too bright and so it
just displays black but then the glow
from it is still apparent if you watch
like uav footage like i do and you see
like missiles blowing up buildings right
when that explosion goes off it goes
black and then back to white because
we're dealing with this effective
dynamic range of what thermal cameras
can handle also this is probably another
one of those situations where whatever
that is in the sky
it's not moving the way it looks like
it's moving because we're now just doing
the same parallax effect except it's on
the horizon lines so once again let's
break this down there is a small chance
it's an alien
this is a ufo it's una we don't know
what that object is it's technically ufo
we don't know what they're filming the
len the flare is obscuring it okay so
wait this is it so far like i'm just
seeing stuff that airplanes film and it
seems like it's going fast because the
plane's moving yeah there's one more
this is it this is someone at the
freaking pentagon was like uh how do i
compress this
and then they bring in a media encoder
and like we're releasing on twitter like
so let's select twitter we got a blurry
dot okay there's an airplane flying
straight filming something it could this
is probably this is most likely an alien
actually this is 100 an alien there's
science can't explain this footage that
you're seeing right here it could be a
word it could be a vampire loch ness
monster sasquatches can fly or it could
be a ghost a massive freaking high-speed
ghost he's like i'm late to haunt this
house
he's like he's like
they're moving in
maybe santa claus
oh
damn
pentagon releases top secret leaked
footage of santa claus that would be
newsworthy
i mean this there's this footage is
devoid of information
like i could literally make you that
in after effects and like i could
release it and it would look exactly the
same run it through about a thousand
filters export as an mp4 about five
times call it a day let's be honest
what is that dot it could be anything
okay it literally could be
anything
in the air it could be an alien
we will never know but unfortunately
it's more likely to be anything else
other than an alien you know
[Music]
[Laughter]
but once again let's be honest there is
a very small percentage there's a small
very very very small chance it could be
an alien there could be an alien behind
that door right now the chances are
pretty much equal i think the thing that
everybody's really hyped about with this
is that the pentagon released it like
the pentagon went like we have this
footage we can't we can't identify
what's in it here is footage of a ufo
slash uap now we want footage of a ufo
as in footage of an alien and they had a
god no it's footage of a ufo like real
footage vfo is like yeah it's real
footage of a ufo so it's footage of real
aliens it's like never mind and then the
news took it and throws a guy on there
goes this could be an alien and sam's
right it could be an alien there could
also be an alien behind the door
in fact maybe all of you watching this
might be aliens right now and i might be
the only real person here they're
freaking interdimensional invaders okay
i'll just say it make fun of me all you
want here's a challenge
i would like to believe that aliens are
real but i think this video footage does
absolutely nothing for the cause
if you know of alien footage that is
more convincing than this or have proof
of aliens
that might convince me that they're real
let us know in the comments below
likewise if any of you guys all happen
to be
pilots that know what all these readouts
and these screens mean or any of you
have other like really solid theories as
to what we could be looking at here not
crazy wacky like it could be a dragon
theories but at real life like oh it was
actually if it was a drone it would work
like this like i'd love to hear like
some down to earth skeptic approaches
what we're looking at here also so yeah
leave some comments down below i would
love to engage with you in some some
discussions here thanks for watching and
don't forget to subscribe until next
time
all right let's do some lunch let's do
it lunch time
mcdonald's here
hey you cut the camera right yeah
[Music]